today the council had an exchange of
views on the future of dcap Common
Agricultural Policy in particular
Minister shared ideas on how to
prioritize of the future cap and on
whether there should be a rebalancing of
the direct support and on the Rural
Development simplification was generally
highlighted as an overall priority for
future policies in order to release the
full economic potential of you farming
and rural areas the Commission presented
to the council its proposal establishing
a multi annual plan for small pelagic
stocks in the Adriatic Sea member states
generally welcomed the discussion but
highlighted some concerns about the
potential social economic impact of the
plan on small-scale fisheries and
potential practical issues with a VD
complex Mediterranean fishery we had a
series of shorter points on unfair
trading practices we discussed the paper
supported by a number of member states
who had a number of concrete and
practical ideas I'm working closely with
Commissioner Bienkowski and Commissioner
Vesta girl and they expect to see the
positive outcome from this collaboration
later on this year the Polish Minister
raised the issue of the fruit sector for
which the European commissioners
provides significant support of about
450 million euro two days since the
Russian embargo upped and August 2014 we
also were able to provide some further
support today by confirming my attention
to propose a rollover of the temporary
exceptional measures for certain fruits
after the first of July 2017